>> Tucker: ALL AGES DRAG SHOWS
POPPING UP ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
DRAG SHOWS FOR KIDS.
ONE OF THEM THE OTHER DAY IN
AUSTIN, TEXAS.
ARE YOU HAVING A GOOD TIME?
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE PART?
>> I SAW YOU GUYS WITH YOUR MOM
WHERE IS BELINDA, RIGHT?
SONIA, WE NEED MORE MOTHERS LIK
YOU IN THE WORLD.
>> HOW OLD ARE YOU?
>> NINE.
>> HELLO, ARE YOU HUNGRY?
>> IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING IF
THEY ARE TARGETING KIDS, THEY
ARE LITERALLY TARGETING KIDS.
♪ SINGING ♪
♪ I HAVE WORKED SO HARD, I
ACTUALLY WORKED MY POTHOLE OFF.
>> SO GLAD IS FOR THIS?
THE HUMAN RIGHTS CAMPAIGN IS FO
THIS?
IT IS HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
36 SHOWS, 18 DIFFERENT STATES,
WE KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE INSIDE
BECAUSE TAYLOR HANSON,
INDEPENDENT JOURNALIST WENT
THERE AND GOT THAT FOOTAGE
TWITTER MERELY SUSPENDED HANSON
FOR TELLING THE TRUTH ABOUT WHA
WAS GOING ON.
TAYLOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON TONIGHT.
I THINK YOUR VIDEO BASICALLY
ANSWERS MY QUESTIONS.
THIS WASN'T AN ADULT THING, THI
WAS A KID THING OR THERE WERE
KIDS THERE, THAT WAS THE POINT,
RIGHT?
TAKE IT YOU'RE COMPLETELY RIGHT
THIS IS MARKETED TOWARD CHILDRE
IT LITERALLY SAYS ALL AGES, I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, BUT THE
VIDEO I WATCHED, IT DOES NOT
ENTITLE ANYTHING THAT INCLUDES
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR ALL AGES
AND THIS.
>> I WILL LET OUR AUDIENCE COME
TO THERE OWN CONCLUSION, BUT WH
SOMEONE WOULD INTENTIONALLY
TARGET CHILDREN FOR THIS, AND M
TO SAY, WITH KIDS THERE I THINK
IT IS OUR BUSINESS.
WHY WOULD YOU BE BANNED FROM
TELLING THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT WA
GOING ON INSIDE?
>> IT'S INTERESTING THAT I WAS
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY SUSPENDED
AFTER REPORTING ON THIS AND
HAVING IT HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
THE REASON I WOULD BE BANNED
BECAUSE YOU HAVE FAKE REPORTERS
LIKE WILL CARL IS FROM USA TODA
AMONGST MANY OTHER SOURCES THAT
WANT TO COME OUT AND SAY THERE
ARE NO CHILDREN THERE, THEY FLA
OUT DENIED THIS EVEN THOUGH
THESE CHILDREN ARE ESSENTIALLY
ON THE VIDEO BEING GROOMED.
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO PUT IT,
THESE CHILDREN ARE BEING GROOME
BY ADULTS.
>> AND OUTLETS LIKE USA TODAY
PRETEND THAT THEY LIE AND THEY
SAY THAT'S NOT HAPPENING WHEN
THIS VIDEO SHOWS THAT IT IS.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO COVER
THAT UP?
>> I THINK IT'S ABOUT THE
NARRATIVE GAME I'VE HEARD OF
SOMETHING CALLED DRAG PHOBIA
THAT HAS BEEN POPPING UP PRETTY
RECENTLY IN MY MENTIONS.
I GUESS I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
MEANS, BUT IF DRAG PHOBIA MEANS
I'M AGAINST FULL-GROWN MEN
DRESSED AS WOMEN SEXUALLY
DANCING AND COMMITTING LEWD ACT
IN FRONT OF MINORS INTENTIONALLY
, THEN YOU CAN
CONSIDER MEAT DRAG PHOBIC TO SA
THE LEAST.
AGAIN, JUST TO BE COMPLETELY
CLEAR, DOING THIS TO KIDS IS A
CRIME AND IT IS CERTAINLY IN
IMMORAL CRIME I AM SURPRISED
THAT PEOPLE SIT BACK.
BUT, TO GET I'M GLAD YOU
MENTIONED THE DADS, TUCKER.
THERE IS A COMMON REOCCURRENCE
IS THERE ARE NO DABS THERE, 99
PERCENT OF THE TIME A LOT OF
THE PEOPLE THAT BRING THE KIDS
TO THE SHOWS ARE SINGLE MOTHERS
WHO HAPPEN TO BE OBESE, I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S A PATTERN OR WHA
BUT PEOPLE ARE TAK